hello welcome back ah welcome
professional youtuber hey everybody
Jesus Jesus Christ okay okay all right
all right
relax I know what I'm doing relax what
am i doing
find Amanda okay let's go Amanda welcome
back to Detroit become a [ __ ] and the
soo epic wrench more is coming
keep watching everybody oh there she is
and I will slag
don't judge me okay it's late I have to
work overtime to get those videos out
you're welcome I know my life is hard
is she supposed to be like the Oracle in
the matrix I really feel like she
reminds me of that character talk to
Alice I know David David Cajun loves the
matrix well I tried okay
no excuse I have no excuse I should have
been more efficient
which is technically hurtful there were
a diary I found its diary but it was
encrypted it may take weeks to decipher
what else the Imam game the walls of the
apartment were covered with drawings of
labyrinths and other symbols like the
other deviants it seemed obsessed with
aura 9 you came very close to catching
that deviant how do you know how is your
relationship with the lieutenant
development and it's the bomb
it's improving I've come to understand
him better and he's growing accustomed
to my presence
Reba sees we're basis we don't have much
time
deviancy continues to spread it's only a
matter of time before the media finds
out about it we need to stop this
whatever it takes I will solve this
investigation Amanda yeah relax Amanda
disappoint you the new case just came in
fine Anderson and investigated mr.
Anderson it's a reference I'm calling it
hey would it be cool if Mark Zuckerburg
just appears out of nowhere
konnichiwa Felix and ningún dissing Mark
Zuckerberg Uday's
now just me all right thank you taxi
driver thank you
look for lieutenant Anderson but by
going to his house I'm sure he'll love
that
it's pretty neat-looking place all right
in have doorbells okay anybody home
nothing like a cold one of the bone
juice with the boys
that is dog
baby kids really loves rain every scene
merlene yes
Oh No hey now don't break the window I'm
not breaking the window I'm looking for
another entrance
I find Connor such a doofus
he'd be turned off by a human if you
can't Somali I don't know I feel like
we're dogs Androids must be so weird
right everyone has a speech said that oh
wow what the heck
dude I thought we were cool man what
happened here
apparently Connor I don't remember his
real name but he did a let's play on
twitch where he played this game and he
talked about the game it's really
interesting the amount of effort that
went into making this it's really really
cool I don't have time to watch all of
it but I would recommend checking it out
ok slight no signs of trauma all right
lieutenant he's gonna love this wake up
and smell the ashes take Hank to the bad
thing all right now means soon when we
embrace do you win get yourself together
yeah you guys keep saying you really got
to maintain a good relationship with him
he's a sweetheart
bath time it's bath time hours yay if a
founders were judge full they would just
hate it seem like such idiots what the
[ __ ] are you doing here a homicide was
reported 43 minutes ago I couldn't find
you at Jimmy's bar so I came to see if
you were at home I must be the only cop
in the world yeah apparently he's
assaulted in his own house by his own
[ __ ] Android can't you just leave me
alone
pragmatic adopt the case they'll assign
someone else and I can focus on my
mission you got their mission that's all
you care about huh listen lieutenant
you're not yourself you should beat it
you hear me well that didn't didn't work
out great I made the right choice there
definitely well nothing changed okay
relax tease I understand it probably
wasn't interesting anyway a man found
dead in a sex club downtown guess
they'll have to solve the case without
us you know probably wouldn't do me any
harm to get some air
there's some clothes in the bedroom
there
I'll go get them what kind of job is
this way it's ok to get go to work
completely smashed cuz I want that job
all right here we go what do you want to
wear oh we get to pick oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh yes oh yeah
hank is gonna get funky yeah don't know
see this I don't get when you see adults
who can't hold their liquor yeah
wonderful me five minutes okay sure yeah
yeah why why disgusting wait Frank
learn more about Hank okay sure I know
he likes to drink
he likes to listen to autumn blues lame
well he also loves pizza and takeout and
whiskey some maggots oh he had a son
hankie boy
he's the broken kind of guy huh oopsie
sorry about the window lieutenant I
really thought you'd been attacked of
course
cyber life will pay for the damage hey
all right let's check this out
that's a big-ass dog dude
I was wonder what it's like to have a
big dog cuz you have a small dog and
they just become like your little teddy
bear you can't really teddy bear up with
a big dog but big dogs seem so much
smarter and loyal you know what do you
think Edgar no one asks your opinion you
loser okay there's some more stuff here
oh yeah
yeah maybe we don't have to comment
about everything
hit
a good dog sumo was wrong with this dog
like deformed what does Hank look like
Hugh Hefner oh listen
Oh sumo how I it that sneer well we made
the right choice in picking this freaky
shirt at least I feel confident about
that one you guys coming about every
choice I make oh why didn't you do that
why don't you do this the streaky shirt
I am 100% confident that's what everyone
wants
everyone loves - streaky shirt and if
that's not today in the case then you're
just a dummy bum
oh yeah we're going on the mission with
the Ninja Turtles but your answer are
you even alive the spare parts in the
Blue Boy alright alright alright
finally some action I want some action
you know some quick time some QTEs man
cute ty
evil
don't let them see us
well we're really sneaking it up good
thing they have the drone that shines on
them they can talk like walkie-talkies
I just realized maybe this is super
annoying to watch if I'm slightly
intoxicated hey I'm sure it's fine
at least I'm not a Hank
okay this is that thing
we're barely making any noise so this is
really cool
what that's where I was born yes
why me
oh I see that's kind of cool
nothing like using your iPad in the rain
the warehouse is up ahead
all right cool so speaking of drinking
alcohol I've been really trying to like
not to stop drinking you know I talking
about Buddhism on this and this let's
play and they talk about you know they
don't booty so drink so I was like okay
well I want to try to cut it out but to
cut it out completely I started doing
every other day leave it to me and then
I hope to do every every other other day
and then every other there are there are
other day and then hopefully I can cut
out completely I doubt it
I'm just full of [ __ ]
okay well that won't work so why am I
even trying it oh that looks cool that
seems like a bad idea
yeah exactly okay and then you'll be too
high what do you want from me you'll be
too high don't you don't even know me
game now I jump on the side I'm trying
to get it there it is okay and then the
truck would be too far alright this game
is really picky I don't know what's amen
[Music]
okay Alexa this is that thing
what am I even doing sure let's do that
why not
well anyway Buddhism am i right
they talk about cutting away your
cravings and talked about on the channel
and you don't realize how desperately
you need certain things or how hard it
is until you try and cut it out just
like I try to completely cut away eating
snacks it's a lot harder than you think
ok that's all I'm saying once again used
to something but I don't want my
cravings to control me alright I have
self-control no I don't but I try ok I'm
getting there
all right we got the blue stuff
what up home dog damn dad you were
trespassing on private property
your presence constitutes a level two
infraction come on this is not a pig
John you're being a total doofus all
right just go with it
John John is need your help John
Oh
there's the drum now this
Just My Luck
it works look I made the right decision
how about that yeah did it just say 66
let's finish up and get out of here John
doesn't care anymore he's like yeah you
know what
you make a good case take some of that
blue stuff baby are you
check the bigger
oh my god this I bet you I bet you
there's gonna be epic in here
Bree
there you go first try as always because
I'm so good at games getting a lot of
cumin saying I'm bad at video games
excuse me have you seen my four night
gameplay
why are you like us
don't you want to be free
don't you want a smaller nose Jesus
those were huge air Prima's
I don't ever want the big nose is on my
team oh I have a big nose you'd be quiet
all right no one asks your opinion you
just mean
[Music]
that's all he can just do that now
she's like okay that was that's all they
can carry let's go okay we did it take
me with you
Oh John come on you were a doofus a
second ago you took a risk for us we
can't just leave him here
I don't know John you're kind of a party
pooper all right sing des mesito they
come with us is that some for X smile
what do you mean the trucks
they're full of bio components
they run on autopilot but they can be
driven manually with a key where is this
key
down there in the control station there
are two human guards you'll have to get
the key without being noticed this is
suicide markers our bags are full we got
what we came for let's go before they
catch us the truck full of spare parts
there'd be enough for all of us we can't
pass this up and if we get killed our
people will have nothing we can't take
that chance is too risky
Alexa get the key wait here if I'm not
back in 10 minutes go without me Marcus
I'm coming with you mom ain't going
alone it's not worth it for both of us
to risk losing our lives also Marcus is
in love with the old guy alright
say wait thought tip damn it
I meant thought us thank you
okay
please
mice please it was a joke okay
can't wait
okay they got the key all right I would
found the key now how do we get it deal
with the guards no no no I didn't mean
to go here you don't have to show me a
cutscene Jesus
and I might deal with the guards
the user interface it really reminds me
of that Xbox game we play which I don't
remember the title of can let them out
quantum break that's it thank you thank
you for telling me appreciate it
sneaky sneaky
no yeah
I was gonna take my kids camping this
weekend so much
okay we can do that
looks like it should be done already
yeah this is what I want to do
idea
last a bit 28 times
oh it's not lit papi look
I love how blind a is and games are like
whatever they are supposed to be you
play Assassin's Creed in this like
you're riding in front of someone I know
right
very epic now I have to shake to get out
wow these guys are genius all right yeah
yeah yeah yeah what am I going return to
group where do I came from I can't walk
on the grass apparently
all right here we go ha did you get it
hello wonderful lady I love you thanks I
respect you
so much just like a respect anyone but
especially you
are we gonna drive no Felix we're not
gonna drive the car okay I'm sorry I was
just I'm excited
Alex
this is not a patient this is so Lavery
I thought it would be fast
[Music]
all right all right all right we did it
everyone all right
I think no it keeps going nevermind
we stole a whole truck bio components
for everybody we couldn't have done it
without Marcus idea
Marcus Marcus I think North is more than
a friend okay
here androids are free free to live in
the dark hoping that no one finds us
free to die in silence waiting for a
change it's never gonna come
but I don't want that freedom
because I'm on a bag for the right to
smile love or stand tall
I don't know about you but there's
something inside me that knows that I am
more than what they say I am alive and
they're not gonna take that from me
anymore
our days of slavery are over what humans
don't want to hear we will tell them
what they don't want to give we take we
are people we are alive we are free oh
my god
oh my all right
I do I can't play anymore I'll see you
guys hello I'm back I do realize that
it's not a new episode I yeah
I apologize for yesterday's episode i
think i think that talked about stop
drinking while I was drinking with a
drew in service go I hope you guys enjoy
that treat this is the place it's the
address in the report okay
that's good going we're going to a strip
club yay
I've never been to one her raid this
will be my first time
edan clung we're gonna see some plastic
Hey
sexiest androids in town now I know why
you insisted on coming here yeah you
know exactly why I Hank don't pretend
you don't want to be here
wait this is a gay bar
no it isn't okay ha
that's why I'm looking at time I ain't
sorry sorry what does this look like a
since created what just happened don't
[ __ ] swag all cases involving
Androids
oh yeah like wasting time is some
pervert who actually will have a look
anyway you don't mind come on let's go
it's starting to stink of booze mmm oh I
don't like that guy
I'm still the lieutenant alright I
demand some respect that text why do
they do that
alright let's examine the Android you
guys kept telling me that everything is
time-based so I have to make sure I
don't waste as much time as I've been
doing going on off on tangents analyzed
okay now we know the serial number of
the blue bud
okay we enjoyed it now let's humanoid it
well there's one right here cardiac
arrest
heart attack nuttin cause of death cause
of asphyxiation
thumbnail beautiful you look beautiful
man
incredible I don't need to see his
little sexy legs they were just into
kinky stuff disgusting
he didn't die of a heart attack he was
strangled yeah I saw the bruising on the
neck yeah that's right Hank in that spot
things too could have been a rough play
we're missing something here think you
can read the androids memory if you can
see what happened
there's a lock thing that I really want
to find I can try wait he can try
reactivation requires its memories to
react that you can do it
it's badly damaged if I can it'll only
be for a minute maybe less I just hope
it's long enough to learn something yeah
chillax dude you're just dead complain
lunch okay tell me what happened he
started hitting me again and again did
you kill him no no it wasn't me it was
the murder man if it wasn't you I didn't
see anything are you alone in the room
was there anyone else with you he wanted
to play with two girls there was another
guy damn it I thought I was fast okay
there was another Android this having
over an hour ago it's probably long gone
no it couldn't go outside dress like
that unnoticed it might still be here if
you could find a deviant among all the
other androids in this place deviants
aren't easily detected it's gotta be
some other way
we should have a dance contest somebody
who saw it leaving the room I'm gonna go
ask the manager a few questions about
what he saw you let me know if you think
of anything search for Android
eyewitness it's you did you know the
victim came in maybe two three times
these guys they don't really talk very
much you know come in do their business
so he wanted two girls what if the plot
twist is that it was a guy mm-hmm and
you know just like whoa didn't expect
that one David caged
need human to access Android excuse me
lieutenant you come here a second
found something maybe can you rent this
Tracy 10 sake Connor we got you sick O
Connor
how does Hank not trust Connor at this
point he's been nothing but loyal why
this one this is not gonna look good on
my expense account
delighted to meet you
follow me I'll take you to your room
okay now what yeah now what
well maybe she saw who leave the room of
course
I'm so stupid
okay all right okay
found her a blue-haired Tracy headed
toward the entrance
it's all something way talking I saw
what the deviant leave the room a
blue-haired Tracy Club policy is to wipe
the androids memory every two hours we
only have a few minutes no witness all
right well she went this way
to do with this one till you changed
your mind oh how oh it's her let's try
this it really looked like her oh my god
this camera it turned back into okay
it saw the blue haired Tracey I know
which way it went they go for it I'm
trying
there are androids everywhere how are
you gonna know which one saw the Tracey
with I know it's direction
give me something there she is
let's get that thought yeah where are
you you tell me now why hang in there
handsome where is she
we saw her go in here there oh my god so
annoying my phone is ringing sorry I'm
sweating
okay I'm sweating I'm trying please
one minute plenty of time he's spending
so much money she went in there
we got you now oh my daughter are you
kidding me
why you have to go and make things so
gasps Hank Hank you spend like hundreds
and hundreds of dollars
stupid passed-out lady I don't care he
surely saw something
oh it fled through the staff door this
is crazy I spent like 600 galleys I know
Hank go run then you schmuck wait I'll
take it from here
oh yeah it's Hank time
get her Hank
no are you kidding me
there's blood there's blue blood Cheers
we're too late
no we're not there's blue blood
oh you're hiding here you little fatty
food her huh
you thought I wouldn't find you huh you
better I defend you pursue quick time
boss bring it shoot that bear No
give her the connor special come on stop
slap me oh no I'm a really expensive
model
please you're gonna to regret this
why are they both fighting me knock over
my oh [ __ ] that didn't work Hank Kuehne
she's crazy
check that girl there you go
Alexa Alexa help me Hank you do
something
oh oh oh they're teaming up not a
problem for candor oh maybe it is Connor
please thought patrol swatch don't think
so
[Music]
jeez that's Christ Connor
oh my god haha shoot just shoot at this
point I'm sorry boom what I try to shoot
her I swear when that man broke the
other Tracey I knew I was next
I was so scared you still a murderer
Arturo begged him to stop but he
wouldn't
and so I put my hands around his throat
then I squeezed until he stopped moving
cool thanks for the confession to kill
him I just wanted to stay alive
I wanted her to hold me in her arms
again made me forget about these humans
[Music]
we have dirty words
come on let's go
what you're just gonna let him go after
all that you're letting them go Hank
like that well Felix didn't like that
there's anyone care about my emotions
huh
they still they're still murdered of the
guy it might be only no guess I'm crazy
[Music]
Jesus Christ it gets very hot in here
guys
oh my god
I only had one displays I have to like
click in and out make sure take me home
country roads estimated remaining time
downloading what do you mean downloading
no did it won't do one of those doofuses
where they don't download the whole game
because I'm not connected to the
Internet oh you can't do this David I'm
not connected to the Internet you
ding-dong okay it downloaded everybody
snow what a nice little change of pace
Luther is neutral I don't know if I'm
neutral with Luther
thirty Fahrenheit that's like zero
degrees right Celsius it's pretty cold
man
I guess that's why it's snowing deeply
[ __ ] okay I'm sorry
what do I do here I'm supposed to look
around Oh what is this game I have to
look around and stuff
press button in this game the weather is
really bad
I've never seen snow before
it's pretty unlike you on the style
but in this we won't meet any humans
along the way
you're a real party party guy Luther I'm
really glad we brought you along
honestly you're making it so much more
enjoyable let's turn on the radio sign
on it to hear your mumbling
peewee news what I'm Pew News where is
it there it is they can use it's 30
degrees people were going to see how do
you know about them
overheard Androids knuckle captured they
said they were humans helping Android to
cross the border what if it was a lie
just another trap
all I know is those androids believed it
until slap will kill them and you
helping them are we not talking about
that what how
and cars are worse in the future great
this doesn't look good
maybe it's like canto well okay Alexei
this is that big it's okay the car the
car is an Android I'm an Android we can
sort this out maybe close the door after
this really looks like that B&W electric
car it's so ugly
No
continue on foot I guess it's 30 degrees
I was right making
I have defense where to spend the night
there's a sign there and there's a sign
right there guys
that's a sign right here guys let's let
out a letter what a carrot take care of
it is that a fanny pack on my back heck
yeah
[Music]
walk it extremely some pirates key code
yeah I mean that car barely had any
cover in it at all so I definitely see
why
oh my god it's creepy Oh No
I have a bad feeling about this one guy
just find shelter we have to get out of
the cold Wow Karen you're really smart
woman you come up with that idea all
right so we can go to the Kraken and go
to the thing the roller coaster all
right this place is awesome
I love this plane this actually looks
pretty cool
I want to let's wonder where they get
abandon find anything especially when
they look so cool the night away we
couldn't spend the night in there oh man
that's crazy
Karen please say something of value is
that an Android
they left you here as well welcome to
parties you're gonna have a whale of a
time oh thank you welcome to pirate
island me hearties you're gonna have a
whale of it
mr. whale then huh
cool that's gonna be us basically we
already check the map
all right what do we got here trying to
point it League of Captain Kraken let's
go to the Kraken it was cracking in the
Kraken this place is falling apart it's
not gonna be easy to find shelter
okay here this six kid
it's not gonna be easier to find shelter
find shelter immediately
looks sane
how was the car not better
Eilis oh wow Luther okay you know what
fair enough he's pretty big
there we go oh my God look at him
compared to Alice
yeah let's not close the door after I
settle in for the night I'll get a fire
going
oh it's brand-new how about that USS
Iowa missing American vessel oh yeah
they're fighting for the Arctic
that's interesting you know you look at
kpop and how manufactured they are
literally they breed them since birth
it's not much different than it was to
Sandra's anyway my assists by the window
with end go Nikki trying to distract me
okay I'll make the fire heat that way we
won't be smoked out
am I actually [ __ ] so I got
distracted by maritza
what do we got
wait what
offer cookie there are some cookies left
would you like some
all right little Tay what do you want
then you spoiled brat
I'm not hungry my Gucci
cool glamour today alright 9 the 9 year
olds
all right let's go get some blankets
all right let's make a bed for that
spoiled little barangay
it's this bad Prada
allas
whoo it's hot in here
all right let's talk to her
Hey look it's a happy family the thing
you will never have
do you think we'll be like instantly if
you stop acting so
yeah I don't know how to be like that
I've never been a part of a family
maybe we can be our own family
be happy in our own way
as long as we're together that's all
that matters
huh look at that let's get your buddy
tuck Alison
why don't cha ker do it
that was in his name was it
tomorrow will be great get some rest
tomorrow's going to be a long day okay
great
yeah I was in children stories in memory
and I'm not gonna tell a single one that
was a you know not a story like that
make we're not for me well that's what I
did this is a story about a little girl
who is scared who was tired of being
afraid she dreamed of being like all the
other girls but
she was different she was different
and that made her very sad then she met
the robot
who was just as lost as the little girl
so they decided to run away together
to try to find a better life they
encountered great dangers along the way
but
but they stuck together so they overcame
all of them along the way
payment
a gentle giant
who promised to protect them
how does historian
they all down
but all stories have boroughs
we reach the end of ours we'll know what
it really meant
time to sleep
we have another long day ahead of us
tomorrow
you going to come say goodnight mr.
LeWitt there was me sorry loser
yes of course
[Music]
he tried to murder you like 20 minutes
ago
wait are we a family now is that what's
happening all right now we can talk to
Tucker I'm just gonna call him that
so what's your tinder profile she's a
sweet girl yes she's very brave mom I
can hear you have you ever heard of ra9
alright now was the first of us to
awaken one day he will rise up and lead
our people and set us all free how does
he know about that
what if Ari and I never comes what if
he's just a story that we tell ourselves
to keep each other going i 9 exists I
believe in him I know he's amongst us
when the time comes we will all see him
Kara
have you ever noticed anything
bo Dallas what do you mean no what do
you mean wait what what does that mean
[Music]
is it all this that why
let's we're not having our uh all right
I'll protect that lace
[Music]
who are you what do you want leave us
alone
don't be afraid I don't wanna hurt you I
can tell by the way you broke into the
house our name is Jerry I'm hard working
here before the park closed we didn't
mean to frighten you but sometimes
humans come to hurt us so we wanted to
see who was there sure what are you
doing here we were looking for shelter
for the night we'll be gone tomorrow a
little girl we haven't seen one for a
long time
children you still up to come and see us
this is so sad she looks at the last few
days have been difficult we have
something to show her something fun
she'll love it does she want to see oh I
don't think she's in she should follow
us then Alice I don't know if it's a
good idea
I don't think you have any choice
Tucker's like did you notice something
about Alice she's actually [ __ ]
don't know if you noticed
what was they named Jerry we can have an
army of Jerry's wouldn't that be our
guest
but we were gonna sleep but you know
the little one can climb on board
the carousel is about to begin
[Music]
it's the first time I've seen her smile
Oh
she hasn't had much to smile about
lately
[Music]
boom no sorry
next up you're going in the deaf drum
palace it's gonna be epic
Hey look at that we almost did
everything look at that look at that hey
look at that
very nice
hope you guys enjoyed another episode of
teh father simulator and I will see you
guys tomorrow with another one good path